ينضم الينا من رام الله اللواء الركن
المتقاعد واصف عريقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه لواء الركن
المتقاعد جحر الديك منذ قليل غاره جديده
هذه المنطقه انطلقت منها الفرقه السادسه
وال باتجاه مخيم النصيرات
ومخيم النصيرات والبريج يعني من المفترض
ان تكون هذه المنطقه باتت تحت سيطره
الجانب الاسرائيلي لاستمرار الغارات عليها
ماذا يعني وماذا بالنسبه لظهر القوات
الاسرائيليه هذا صحيح يعني المفترض ان
يكون الجندي الاسرائيلي بحسب ادعائه انه
لا يحتاج ل مدفعيه ولا طائرات تسانده هذا
ان دل على شيء يدل على ان هناك مقاومه
ضاريه اي تستبسطهاش
معه تجبره على التراجع اي
والانسحاب يعني الطائرات حينما تقصف تقصف
حينما يتعرض الجنود الاسرائيليين لل لخطر
الاصابه وضرا الاشتباك ينسحبوا من المكان
وتاتي الطائرات لتتيح لهم المجال بالعوده
سواء كان من الجو او من المدفعيه البريه
والبحريه وكما تحدثت في حضرتك وقلت ان
يعني حجر الديك هي القفز الاولى كانت
للدبابات وللجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا ان دل
على شيء يدل على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
متعثر حتى الان وانه لم يصل الى المرحله
الثالثه والرابعه من الخطه العسكريه التي
يفترض ان تنفذ على ارض الواقع اذا ما اريد
الاهداف ان تتحقق والمراحل هي التقدم
التمدد التطويق التطهير اذا نحن نتحدث عن
المرحله الثانيه بمعنى ان حتى التمدد لم
يكتمل لانه يحاول ان يتمدد وتمنعه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لذلك هو في حاله الكر
والفر وهذه الحاله لا يمكن ان ينجز فيها
العسكري اي هدف على الارض هل ينسحب ذلك
لواء واصف على بيت حنون وبيت لاهيه وهذه
المناطق كانت من اوائل المناطق التي دخلها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في عمليته
البريه اخت فدا حيثما حيثما سقطت قذيفه
وحيث ما قصفت طائره هذا يعني انها منطقه
سيطره للمقاومه الفلسطينيه ولا يوجد فيها
حتى وجود للجنود الاسرائيليين لانه لا
يمكن الطائره ان تقصف جنودها لا يمكن
للمدفع ان يقصف جنوده فبالتالي هو يقصف
اهداف فلسطينيه وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل
على ان نسبه التمدد حتى نسبه التمدد وليس
السيطره لاحظ يا اخت فدا هناك فرق ب كبير
بين التمدد وبين السيطره حتى التمدد اخذ
يتقلص كنا نتحدث قبل اسبوعين عن 50% اليوم
ربما اقل من 40% من تمدد الجيش الاسرائيلي
على ارض قطاع غزه بمعنى ان هناك 60% من
ارض قطع غزه يسيطر عليها بالنيران اما من
الطائرات واما من المدفعيه البريه ومن
المدفعيه البريه وهذا طبعا مخزي للجيش
الاسرائيلي يعني حينما يدخل الشهر الثالث
وهناك اربع فرق عسكريه من نخبه النخبه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ويذهبون الى هدفين ولم
يحققوا ايا من الهدفين وعدلوا على الاهداف
وايضا من المعيب عسكريا ان يتم تعديل
الاهداف اذا لم تتم تحقيق الاهداف الاولى
يعني ممكن تعديل الخطط تبعا للوقائع
الميدانيه ممكن تعديل الخطط هذا واضح ولكن
تعديل الاهداف دون تحقيق الاهداف الاساسيه
هذا معيب ومخزي وهزيمه للجيش الاسرائيلي
وانا اعتقد انه لم يعد خافيا على احد
العالم كله الان يشاهد ويقارن والعالم كله
الان يعرف التكتيكات العسكريه وال المستوى
المتدني الذي وصل اليه الجندي الاسرائيلي
في كفاءته القتاليه وفي روحه المعنويه طيب
لواء واصف وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه تتحدث
عن صفقه محتمله لبيع ذخائر مدفعيه عيار
155 ملمترا والمعدات المرتبطه بها
لاسرائيل كيف يمكن ان ينعكس ذلك على الارض
في
المعركه يعني اعتقد حينما تحدث قبل قليل
ال الامريكي الخبير الامريكي وقال مخزيه
هو فعلا مخزيه استخدام هذه الاسلحه
والذخائر خاصه ذخائر 155 155 ملم
بالمناسبه هذ هذا تخصصي وحتى في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تخصصت عليها هذه تستخدم
ضد الجيوش لا تستخدم ضد
ال المدنيين وضد المناطق السكنيه التي
يوجد فيها مدنيين وخاصه المنث منها هذا
السلاح المحرم دوليا لانه ينفجر فوق
الرؤوس ويؤدي الى اصابات كثيره وخطيره و
وهي محرمه دوليا ومع كل ذلك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تصر على ارسال مثل هذه
القذائف وتقول مع الاسف يعني حينما يتحدث
وزير الخارجيه بلينكن ويقول من اجل الدفاع
اي دفاع هذا يا سيد بلينكن وان هذه
القذائف تستخدم في قطاع غزه هل هي دفاعيه
ام هجوميه ويعني انتم في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ايضا يعني فتره من الفترات
اعترضتهم على استخدام استخدام ال القنابل
المحرمه دوليا
والقنابل الغير ذكيه كما كما تم وصفها
علما بانه الجيش الاسرائيلي يعرف تماما
ادق التفاصيل عن الاهداف التي يقصفها وباد
ق القنابل ولكنه يريد ان يقتل لان الهدف
هو قتل الفلسطيني وليس استخدام قنابل ذكيه
او غير ذكيه او استخدام اسلحه انا اعتقد
انه ما ما يجري على الارض واستخدام اكثر
من 100,000 طن من المتفجرات لا لزوم لها
الطائره لا لزوم لها المدفعيه لا لزوم لها
ان كان هناك جنود حقيقيين يقاتلون على
الارض كما هي المقاومه الفلسطينيه لاحظي
يا اخت فدى المقاوم الفلسطيني يخرج من تحت
الانقاظ اسلحته متواضعه بسيطه جدا صناعه
محليه صناعه محليه ويبرع ويبرع في
الاشتباك مع الجيش الاسرائيلي ويقتل عدد
كبير منه ويجر عدد كبير ويقنط الدبابه
ويؤثر ويؤثر في الروح المعنويه عند الجنود
الاسرائيليين
وقتها اللواء الركن المتقاعد واصف وريقات
الخبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه
من رام الله